hi everybody I'm Nancy O'Dell bringing
you the et interview
well right now we're just trying to you
know get our routine to music it's just
you know it's the first dance so we're
just trying to you know make sure the
bad habits go away like standing up
straight but I have to say he's pretty
musical so when I turn the music on
there was no need to really teach him
how to count music I think Judy Cydia
it's a musical background right I just
play yeah I play trumpet chord and blah
blah blah
yeah it's marching band marching baby I
very clean I have to bring a little
protein bar a little little thing food
that I just drink water haven't lost a
pound though say that you're serious
then I know I need to lose about I need
to lose about 10 pounds and I thought oh
this would be a free way to lose the 10
pounds is it be on Dancing with the
Stars wait till we do the other dances
so far just great
hopefully I'll be in it long enough to
lose the 10 pounds this is our trophy me
when I was on to do character no way
they're gonna have to redo it and just
cut that part off imagine us winning
he really was hoping for Derek Hough
that's what I know yeah we should huffs
in the other room I think you just got a
big box of razors he goes to razors like
you can't believe it's unbelievable
he's still tough